- [Voiceover] Let y of x
equal to the cube, be equal
to the cube root of x to the 3rd plus one.
Which of the following is equivalent
to y of y of x?
Alright, this is gonna be fun.
So we know that y of
x, y of x, is equal to
the cube root of x to the 3rd plus one.
Which of the following is
equivalent to y of y of x?
Well, to evaluate y of y of x,
y of y of y of x,
everywhere where we see an extra,
we would just replace it with a y of x.
It's kind of confusing, it might seem
a little bit daunting cause
it's referring to itself,
but it should all make sense in the end.
So we're gonna have something
to the 3rd power plus one,
and in this case that
something is y of x, y of x.
So what's y of x equal to?
Well it's equal to all of this business.
So let me write this down, so
this is going to be equal to
this is going to be equal
to, the cube root of,
the cube root of, give myself some space,
so y of x is
the cube root of
x to the 3rd plus one,
now we're going to raise
that to the 3rd power.
We're gonna raise that to
the 3rd power, plus one.
And so we just have to evaluate this.
So what is this going to be?
Well, this is going to be the cube root,
the cube root of, well, what
we have right over here,
if I have to take the
cube root of something,
but then I raise it to the 3rd power,
this is like raising something to the 1/3,
and then raising that to the 3rd.
Well that's just gonna give me this thing,
all of this business right over here,
is just going to evaluate
to x to the 3rd plus one.
Once again, if I just take
the cube root of something,
of whatever this is and then
raise that to the 3rd power,
that's going to be this
original something.
Maybe I should put a,
if I take the cube root
of a, and if I raise it to the 3rd power,
that's just going to be a here.
That's all I did right over here.
The cube root of x to the 3rd
plus one to the 3rd power,
is just gonna be x to the 3rd plus one.
And then now, we have the plus one,
so this is going to be
equal to the cube root
of x to the 3rd plus two,
x to the 3rd plus two,
which is that choice right over there.